non-minimalists
how do you reduce your entertainment
expenses
and still keep your kids happy
you know here's the thing like uh you're
not i so i have a five year old and
keeping her entertained is generally
not that expensive dude i have seen i
have been around
you bex and ella i can't even count how
many times uh-huh
and never has money been involved in
making ella happy
well i take the bag we went to
disneyland that cost some money but it
did but by and large
like when we're at your house hanging
out or
wherever we're going for a walk or we
were you know watching the uh gay pride
parade i mean they're
very very few times where i've been
hanging out
uh where mariah and i've been hanging
out with the three of you and we've had
to spend money to keep the kid happy
minimalism is not about deprivation and
we do want to make sure our kids are
happy but we also want to make sure that
we take care of their
their well-being they're they're
well-fed
yes we want them to be entertained but i
also i'm less worried about
the perpetual entertainment because ryan
if i just wanted to entertain
ella all day i would just turn youtube
on and she would watch peppa pig for 14
hours a day
and it'd be a miserable existence long
term she'd be pacified in the moment
so how do i work on entertaining her i
focus less on entertaining her
and i i focus more on nourishing her and
i don't just mean
like through food although that is
certainly important but how do i nourish
her mind how do i get her engaged how do
i keep her
learning but then when i think about
money and entertainment
one of her favorite toys right now is i
i bought a lamp recently it's like a
desk lamp
because i get up early and i need a lamp
on my desk because it's just
super dark there when i'm writing and
it came in this oversized box you know
when you get something and you're like
why is the
box that like yeah like you order like
you order a bottle ibuprofen from amazon
yeah and it shows up in the six foot
coffin right with a bunch of packing
material in it
right yeah this one had this massive box
for a lamp that is about as big as if
you're watching this on youtube it's
about as big as this mic
stand so it's a decent sized lamp but
the box is almost as big as me
and it is a fort a castle a spaceship
it is everything that she wants uh with
that but
that said i also buy her toys right i
don't want to deprive her
so she has a nice bin of toys that she
likes to play with
that are interactive that help nourish
her mind so she's not passively just
entertaining herself she's actively
entertaining herself so maybe the better
question is how can we
actively entertain our kids as opposed
to
pacifying them absolutely